Pete Thamel back here on the show how
are you Pete I'm good how are you I'm
doing well
so let's bang this out I know you but
you said you're on the runway at
LaGuardia right now which I appreciate
you calling in from yes in the spirit of
breaking federal law I may be doing it
too well I mean look so let's get to it
for those who may not have read what you
wrote break it down
nuts and bolts about what what's what's
going on the world of college hoops sure
so essentially there's been this wide
sweeping federal probe that resulted in
10 arrests at September that has kind of
handcuffed and put the mushroom cloud
over this court and there are two
hearings sort of perfunctory deals in
New York yesterday and I wrote a story
that basically said that the information
that they have in Discovery right now
that the feds collected over years of
wiretaps at document collection a bank
record collection etc are explosive
enough to indelible alter the face of
college basketball as we know it the
sport as we know it includes Hall of
Fame coaches top prospects and and
obviously blueblood programs and so
what's the timing on this best you can
tell here I mean that's the bet is the
magic question I probably got 200 texts
in the last 24 hours from coaches being
like what's the timing what's the time
because it affects our option here's the
thing it's not like they're just gonna
have like document release day that's
all gonna come out so you know I quoted
a Dana Richmond a very smart law
professor at Columbia who who said like
you know something's gonna come out with
pretrial motions some may never come out
in essentially it's probably going to
come in terms of draft some could just
come out at trial when you know you know
as as they're presenting evidence in the
courtroom if one of these three cases
types of this ends up going to trial
so the the ambiguity of this is one of
the most fascinating parts rich because
it's a ticking time bomb destined to go
off but no one knows when or how much is
that smell and you say they're Hall of
Fame coaches that are gonna be involved
in this sort of thing expected to be yes
that's correct rich so if that's the
case then somebody's gonna know some
names somewhere correct that's talking
about it but it doesn't really want to
talk about right I mean that they're
somebody knows that a protective order
rich
so it's interesting I think that the
dynamics you're a really fascinating
there's there are multiple pensions
pushing up against each other
mm-hmm Pete saml joining me here from
the runway are you being pressured to
hang up the phone Pete I am NOT okay I'm
not everyone's kind of on their phone
now it's a Delta shuttle from Liguria to
Boston is a little bit of a you know
it's a commuter operation who is the
central figure in this whole thing what
can you tell me about Andy Miller here
an NBA agent who seems to be the focuser
at 40 my my yahoo sports colleague and I
wrote a very in-depth profile of Aunt
Eller probably in november/december and
essentially in it looked the agent
business is pretty much fundamentally
corrupt in terms of the recruiting not
every single guy but you know the the
that landscape is viewed as a majority
of the guys are making illicit payments
to players their families in order to
get clients that's sort of a
fundamentally understood part of that
game in within that space Pat and I
wrote in that profile you know Andy
Miller was considered one of the most
brazen operators if not the most brazen
operator he's had you know multiple
lawsuits but against me still kevin
garnett from an agent named Eric
Fleischer which is how he got to start
the business sort of you know regarded
in that space and we quote people on a
record saying is an unscrupulous
operator so you know they went to these
computers which you can extrapolate say
that they have you know the feds did the
day this all happened so you know if
you've sharp laid it out and said that
they have access to all his bank records
all this information and he was
bankrolling Christian Dawkins who is the
middleman who we also profiled at Yahoo
Sports earlier in this case who was you
know everybody I was paying everyone
it's going to touch a lot of players but
it's also going to touch a lot of
coaches and programs to that that
potential information so alone let's
just get paint paint me paint me the
most likely scenario here Pete that this
all comes out right let's say it all
comes out but I like how you say it's
not gonna be like a document day in the
same way like it's signing day right
yeah so yeah pick up FBI hat so so at
some point where this whole thing comes
to an end and then it gets dropped in
the NCAA slap to figure out what to do
or you think that this might be a case
where it gets so bad the federal
government absolutely actually steps in
and we might have to rethink the way
that we have amateur athletics in this
country you know those are great
questions and I don't know the answer to
it because I don't know how much of this
stuff is going to get released I do
think a lot of it eventually will get
out but I don't know how much I don't
know if the government is going to be
compelled to hand over information to
the NCAA I don't know how much would be
subject to open records requests public
record so there are a lot of variables
here and this I surprise you but I
wanted journals in school and not law
school so a lot of it is out of it by
very limited intellectual threshold in
terms of like the nuances or the
legalities of this but the that the
smart people that I've talked to about
this and you know but sort of quoting
throughout this case indicate that it's
probably going to come out at drips and
drabs but it's it's gonna be it's gonna
be wide sweeping and I think we're
taking off rich there we go there you go
Pete tamel thanks for joining appreciate
it Pete family Yahoo Sports the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience